[Music]
all right this one really doesn't have
any info so it is a Jason chenny version
where we just riff r r there's a guy in
Mexico and he orders a mobile phone
online he opens the Box what's in it
Joe hello oh he ordered a on off phone
and it comes over it's Mexico yeah
something else is in the Box cash o
that'd be nice here I'll give you I'll
give give you a hint cash or drugs dance
I'll cut it out
okay a chameleon conf you guessed so
fast close close watch watch watch
watch dynamite oh it's a grenade grenade
got it yeah it's a grenade he received a
grenade in the mail a dildo grenade from
the cartel no from T-Mobile oh they
don't really know why or how wait did it
open and then did it explode no it
didn't detonate it's a it's an actual
like real oh it's a [__] straight up
grenade straight up grenade yeah what's
that on top of it that's a gender it's a
caramel corn I don't know maybe that's
how they look he ordered a phone he
opened the box and it was a grenade yep
that's dangerous I think sounds like a
sidekick three you're a post office guy
and you're just you had no idea there's
a grenade in that package you don't know
what you're delivering probably thrown
on the [__] step tip your mailman
so uh he ever like how did this happen
and why so it's a gender deal right yeah
it's got to be did it's definitely not a
gender
reveal he ordered this phone he's just
ordering a phone did he go on T-Mobile's
website it doesn't say at all what site
Boo mobile or cricket sounds like a
cricket thing yeah probably Cricket for
me it feels like it's cartel related
could be mint mobile do you
think situation it's it's probably just
the [__] shipping people's [__] up
right what website did you get this off
of cuz he probably just
ave.com maybe say is it a real grenade
but yeah so the what happened is he
called uh the army they came over and
they why thought not the cops you could
just call the Army has a number it just
says he called the Army and they came
over and then they had to defuse it
maybe because the Army handles stuff
like that I want to know the Army's
phone number maybe the local be all you
can be maybe the maybe the actual you
call a
recruiter I have a grenade he goes hey
after this you're considering joining
what if I call a Salvation Army cuz they
need to Salvation me with a grenade from
a grenade now that's next level thinking
n they'll never show up anywhere dude
that's big brain I'll pay you $2.99 for
this yeah yeah yeah dude so they said
it's unclear who sent it uh grenades
also are illegal in Mexico to have can't
but it's it's to his name and his
address yeah so so they arrested him no
they didn't arrest him they knew that he
he didn't like he did not so weird to
order a grenade wait I have a question
how do you
call how do he make a phone call if he
didn't have a phone cuz he bought the
phone or was he like trying to dial the
grenade he's like this ain't
working if it was just a novelty phone
it just looks like a grenade pull but
it's actually a phone yeah hey it's like
a basketball phone a yeah ex yeah yeah
those back in the day and the arm's like
hey your grenades
it could have been I have that same
grenade um not live OB you used to have
that I have it right you have it in here
some pH service too with that grenade
yeah okay stand by while Joe spends the
next 7 minutes trying to find you have
it with you yeah hella yeah grenades
yeah you brought a what if this guy what
if this guy [__] crossed the wrong
people and they're sending him a
message that's that's that's barsy
that's a phone bar a little I have to
fill it up with explosives but I got it
is that real oh it just doesn't have
anything in it it's a paper weight oh
but it's the real one like the real
shell it's a real deal grenade but they
disarmed it there's no yeah the bottom
has a hole Yeah Yeah Yeah the bottom has
a hole take out the pin first I can
catch here don't catch I was like it's
heavy it's very heavy but it's the exact
one in the picture feel
terrible hello it's cool phone you sure
this
is I guess the crazy thing is that
there's saying that uh lately drug
cartels are using a lot more bombs in
everything that they're doing maybe
because of the shootings are just like
eh too too much evidence it says over
the past 6 years cops have seized over
600 uh explosives yeah explosive devices
what if that's that means that 600
phones are missing what if that was
supposed to go to a a person as like
this is your assassination tool use this
oh you know and then it went to the
wrong person what yeah that's what I'm
saying it's got his name and his address
on it so it's like the wrong package you
know what I mean like it was it was
maybe at the T-Mobile store where they
also do T-Mobile and assassin
accessories like you know how like in
[__] 007 you go into like a church
but in actuality it's like a [__]
they got a arms dealer in the back or
whatever what if the T-Mobile is a front
for that and then they're just like all
right phone phone phone gun grenade and
then they sent it to the wrong Hector
Gonzalez
I because it's probably like 100 Hector
Gonzalez 100, there's so many Hector
Gonzalez it's a common name so many he
like Hector Gonzalez so it's like [__]
like and the rest of them are just
getting phones they're all pissed off
yep and they're like I'm not that one
and then there's an e there's an evil
Hector Gonzalez who gets a phone and
he's
like [__] hat it maybe his
instruction was used the package to
assassinate so he just has a phone and
he finds a [__] and he throws it at
him you know but it it doesn't explode
you know what I'm thinking you know how
like when um you have places that are
secret other things like you know in
Breaking Bad they go to this vacuum
store and then depending on what they
order the guy is like oh so you want
that yeah cuz they set a specific type
of vacuum yeah yeah yeah maybe he
accidentally ordered a specific kind of
phone that was supp be yeah he ordered
the [__] old school noia that no one
wants anymore you got the rose gold or
something right oh we got the rose gold
in the back like he accidentally said
the perfect words like well it'll be at
your house
shortly have a blast
Hector okay yeah he's like all right
just a phone and then that guy laughs to
himself he's like like I love my
job
how cool would that be is having like a
front store you come in and then it's
like a pager store store would you have
Joe like JK news yeah what is what is JK
JK
news I have a pet store and then what
are you selling in the back selling
panas dude guns guns guns 100% why would
a pet store be the best friend Joe's got
a gun store and he's selling pets in the
bag illegal
opposite hey want some mice by the way
guess how Joe moves guns around the
world check this
out all right so you get a dog okay and
then you know how dogs have dog vests
yeah you put that [__] in there
especially where they carry the water
bottles no one would ever know you put a
you put guns in there yeah why would you
check it in a dog service animal yeah
you put the guns where you put the
bottles and no one could even
tell or if you if you want to move guns
internationally you buy the gun mhm then
you fly well you sell it use that money
you buy buy a you buy a plane then
planes are too big no no then no you buy
a small plane like a $30,000 plane then
you go to like Venezuela or whatever and
then you sell that plane for guns you
guys out of order it's clean you buy the
gun then you trade the gun with cocaine
for a plane then after the cocaine you
get a plane then you buy a pile to fly
you there and then what if your plane
gets searched what if your pilot's name
is Hector Gonzalez did you buy a Pilot
your plane gets searched they got
cocaine in the plane a person you I mean
you you rented him ah you hired him you
hired you hired him mail order
pilot the genius thing about your scheme
is that even if the cops search it
there's nothing there not a m
zero they're like where's the guns we
know you have it it's all in here
and then they start ripping up the plane
and it's like no the value is here you
stupid son of a [__] was it it's washed
it's completely cleaned up you let them
rip the plane up yeah and then when they
can't find it he's like you want some
mice oh yeah you got get my back hey you
got a mice guy you got a mice
guy